- [Male Voice] I can assure you that what
you will observe is a vast wasteland.
(background noise drowns out other sound)
(instrumental pop music)
- [Male Voice] And
uncorrupted communication.
(instrumental pop music)
- No young kid growing up ever dreams
of someday becoming a businessman.
He wants to be a fireman,
a sponsored athlete
or a forest ranger.
The Lee Iacoccas, Donald Trumps,
and Jack Welches of the business world
are heroes to no one
except other businessmen
with similar values.
I wanted to be a fur
trapper when I grew up.
So that's what I'm gonna
talk about tonight,
the kind of odyssey of wanting
to be a fur trapper to
becoming a garmento (laughs).
I was born in a little French
Canadian town in Maine,
and when I was seven years old,
the whole family, the six of us,
got into our automobile
with everything we owned
and moved to Burbank, California.
And I couldn't speak English,
and I was put in school right away,
'cause it was the law,
and I stayed in school
for about three days
and I ran away from school.
And so when I was young
I could play baseball,
and throw a football as well as anybody,
but when it came time
to do an actual game,
I always fumbled the ball,
and I soon learned that
team sports and stuff
was not my thing.
And I spent my early
childhood in the hills
above Griffith Park there
in San Fernando Valley
and high school days hopping freights
around the country.
So I've kind of taken a different path,
and spent a lot of days in the jails.
(laughs) But in those days it was illegal
not to have a job.
It was called wandering about aimlessly
with no apparent means of support.
(audience laughing)
And it was a crime, so anyway,
one of my favorite quotes
about entrepreneurs
is if you wanna understand
the entrepreneur,
study the juvenile delinquent.
(audience laughing)
'Cause they're saying, this sucks.
(laughs) And I'm gonna do it my own way.
So when I was about 12 or so,
I got in with a bunch of falconers,
in the San Fernando Valley, some older men
who didn't mind taking
in a bunch of young guys
and teaching 'em falconry,
and one of the first lessons I learned
that kind of carried
with me my whole life,
I've been kind of a
student of Zen philosophy,
not religion or anything, just philosophy,
most of my life, and
when a 12 year old kid
has to go out and trap a wild goshawk
and then put him on his fist
and hold him on there with jesses
and the hawk baits off
over and over again,
you put him back on,
and you stay up with him all night,
until he finally falls asleep on your fist
early in the morning,
and that's a real quick
way of building trust,
well the Zen master would have to ask,
who is getting trained here?
(audience laughing)
Well, climbing the hawks' nests
kind of led to climbing for its own sake,
and when I was 16 years old,
I drove my old '40 Ford that I overhauled
in auto shop class to Wyoming,
and I climbed Gannet Peak,
the highest peak in Wyoming.
That was the first mountain I climbed,
and I got pretty hooked,
and I spent the summer
in Jackson Hole and kind of learned
to rock climb,
and in those days if you're climbing
with Converse tennis shoes
and my first rope I stole
from the telephone company.
It was an old manila rope.
But the pitons in those days,
you know those spikes you drive
in the cracks, were made in Europe,
and they were made of soft steel,
and they were meant to be used just once.
The Europeans' attitude
was to conquer them,
you conquer mountains, you know?
The conquest of Everest,
this kind of stuff,
and they felt like well,
you do a first ascent of a route,
and you leave all the pitons in place,
and it makes it easier
for the second group.
Well, we were kind of brought up
with reading John Muir
and Thoreau and Emerson
and we had an attitude that you go
into the mountains but
you don't leave any trace
of having been there,
so when I was, I guess
about 18 or something,
I went out and I bought myself a forge
and an anvil and some hammers
and a book on blacksmithing.
I taught myself how to blacksmith,
and I started making
pitons out of hard steel,
out of just bar stock of hard steel.
And made 'em for myself,
and then they worked so good,
because you could put 'em in
and take 'em out repeatedly,
and then I made some for friends
that I was climbing with,
and then friends of friends wanted some,
so then I started selling 'em.
I could make two an hour,
and I started selling 'em
for a dollar and a half each.
Doesn't sound like much money,
but you gotta remember that pitons,
the European pitons were selling
for 15 cents each, so it
was 10 times the price,
but by that time we were doing
state of the art rock climbs,
and you had to have my pitons
if you wanted to do those climbs.
You couldn't get up those climbs,
and pretty soon we're starting to do
multi day climbs on big walls in Yosemite,
like El Capitan where you
spend 10 days up there,
and you couldn't possibly
carry enough pitons
to do the climb, so
we'd just carry like 40
or so pitons and use
'em over and over again,
and so I'm selling these things
out of the back of my car,
and I'm working, my shop was in Burbank,
but I was surfing already at that time.
I started surfing in
1955 I think in Malibu,
and I'd had everything portable,
so I'd go down to the
beach like County Line
and stuff and I'd carry my 138 pound anvil
down to the beach (laughs),
and I'd work on the beach
and get hot and sweaty,
and then I'd go in and surf,
and in those days you were wishing people
would come by and go surfing with ya.
(laughs) Believe it or not.
(laughs) So anyway, I never, ever,
wanted to be a businessman,
'cause those were the days when
you thought businessmen were grease balls
and that was the last
thing you wanted to be,
but I just happened to be a craftsman
that every time I came
back from the mountains,
I had more ideas for how to
improve various equipments,
and I don't consider
myself an inventor at all.
I'm an innovator, and I look at any piece
of industrial design or something
and I just happen to see ways of how
to make it better, so that's how
I got trapped into being a businessman.
The problem is, I wasn't
making any money doing this,
because I was just too idealistic.
I mean, I'd spend thousands of dollars
in making some tooling and
dies and stuff like that
that you're supposed to
amortize over three years,
and in three months I'd have a new idea
on how to improve it,
so I was kind of knocking myself off.
But you can't make any money doing that,
but on a climbing trip to Scotland,
in the winter of, it must have been
about mid 60's, I bought
myself a rugby shirt,
and I thought, oh, this would make
a great climbing shirt,
because it had a really tough material.
It had a collar.
In those days we used
to love Off with Cracks.
I mean nobody does Off
with Cracks anymore.
(laughs) But it really shreds
your clothes and stuff.
Anyway, it had a collar,
so the gears things
wouldn't cut into your neck,
and it was real colorful.
It was blue and yellow and red,
and in those days active
sportswear for men
was gray sweatpants and sweatshirts.
That was it.
Men did not wear colorful clothes,
so I started wearing this and climbing
and all my friends are going, wow,
where'd you get that?
That's really a great looking shirt.
(audience laughing)
So being a natural entrepreneur
the lights came on
and I started importing a few,
and sure enough they sold like crazy,
and then one of my early products
was a pair of shorts.
I had an idea for a really
tough pair of shorts,
double seated, and so I made the pattern,
and my Korean friend, Yung Sun Sun Wu,
in fact, she's sitting right here,
did the sewing, and we made them
out of a chair duck, canvas
duck that was so heavy
she had to use a walking foot machine
that you use for sewing
quarter inch thick leather,
and anyway she sewed 'em up,
and she put them down on the table,
and they stood straight up.
(audience laughing)
And she was laughing,
so anyway that was the beginning
of our stand up shorts.
You might say they were
hand forged shorts.
Anyway, I got into making
more and more clothing for climbing,
and business was taking off,
but it really took off when
I saw my friend Doug Tompkins,
who started Esprit, and he was wearing
a Fila wool sweater, but it was brushed,
and it was real fuzzy, and I thought,
wow, that thing would make a great thing
for climbing and stuff,
if it was made out of synthetic.
It would dry a lot more quickly.
So my wife went down to the Cal Market
in LA where, it's the garment area,
and she looked around
and found some fake fur,
and you know the kind of?
And she bought some and it was the stuff
that you use in Kansas
for covering your toilet seats (laughs).
Real chic stuff.
(laughs) So we made up a jacket,
and sure enough, you
could fall into a river
in the winter and take the thing off
and shake it and all
the water would come out
and you'd put it back on,
and it would save your life.
Well, that piled jacket
evolved into Synchilla,
which was a much more
sophisticated version,
and then all of a sudden the sales
just took off like crazy,
because up till them I was selling stuff
strictly to climbers, hard core dirt bags.
(audience laughing)
And now you got all these New Yorkers
buying this thing to wear
in their Gold Edition Jeep Cherokee
to drive to their Connecticut home.
(audience laughing)
So (laughs) kind of in the mid eighties
we were growing the
business 40, 50% a year,
and it was just taking off,
and so we were growing the business
by all the traditional ways.
We were opening new
dealers, wholesale accounts,
and we were buying mailing lists
for people who didn't request a catalog
but we'd send 'em one anyway.
We opened up our own retail stores,
and it was just going lickety split,
and in 1989, we had ramped up
to do another 50% increase in business,
and we had bought all the inventory,
and hired tons of people,
and then in 1990, a recession hit,
and instead of growing 50%,
we only grew 20%, but
we were so strung out
by growing that quickly every year
that we had not cash reserves,
and at the same time our bank
was going belly up itself,
and wouldn't give us any more money.
My accountant introduced me to the mafia.
(laughs) Who wanted 28% interest.
(audience laughing)
I mean that's how desperate we were.
Almost lost the business,
and I had to lay off 20% of our workforce,
which is the worst thing I've ever had
to go through in my life,
because a lot of these
people were friends,
and it was absolutely my fault,
and I swore I'd never ever wanna
be in that situation again,
but we had to do it to save the company,
and I realized that my company
had become part of the problem.
I was completely unsustainable.
And I was doing everything the way
you're supposed to in America,
grow like crazy, and so I took
10 of the top people in the company,
and we all, even though we
couldn't hardly afford it,
we all went down to the real Patagonia
down in Argentina, and we walked around
in the wilderness for,
we had to walk for
about a week or 10 days,
and we'd walk for half an hour
and then we'd all sit down in a circle,
in a really nice place,
and then we'd say, okay,
why are we in business anyway?
I mean none of us ever
wanted to be in business.
Not one had a business degree,
and we were all there for
completely different reasons
than your normal business,
and so we had to
communicate what that was.
And so we started writing down
what our values were,
and one of the important things
is that we wanted to make
the best quality product.
I mean we were coming from a background
of making life saving equipment,
making the best climbing equipment
in the world, and we wanted
to do the same thing with clothing.
It was really important that we were
a product driven company,
and that our product was not stock.
Our product was not the company
that was gonna be sold someday,
but our product was these tools
and this clothing.
And we were gonna put that
in the front of the wedge
and the whole rest of the company
was gonna follow the product.
So that was really important for us.
We didn't wanna compromise on that,
and then secondly, but,
my chief designer at the time said,
we can make the best
quality climbing hardware.
We can't make the best clothes.
I said, well why not?
Well, the best shirt is a Giorgio Armani
handwoven Italian fabric,
and the buttons are hand sewn,
and it's an impeccable thing.
It's a work of art, and it
costs 300 dollars, minimum.
If we started making stuff like that,
we'd be out of business.
Well I said, what
happens if you throw that
in a washing machine?
Oh, well, you can't do that.
It's gotta be dry cleaned.
I mean, it'll shrink.
It'll fall apart.
I said, that's not very good quality.
(audience laughing)
So part of this book is defining
what we mean by quality in clothing.
We had to figure out what is quality,
and what is quality for our customers
and for ourselves?
Because we were our own customers.
And then the next thing
we wanted was flex time.
We wanted to be able to take off a month
or two and go on an expedition,
and do that two or three
times a year or more.
(audience laughing)
So that's the name of the book.
That's where I got the name for the book,
'cause we've had a company policy
that one of the lessons of surfing
or powder skiing or any of those
kind of sports is that you don't go
surfing next Tuesday at 2 o'clock.
'Cause you may show up
there and it's flat,
or blown out, and you're a loser.
(audience laughing)
So we have a company policy
that when the surf comes up,
everybody drops their work
that is a serious surfer
and they go surfing.
(audience cheering)
You just gotta be careful
you don't have 100% of
your employees surfers.
(laughs) So that means you gotta hire
very responsible people,
and then let 'em get their work done,
whenever they feel like.
(audience laughing)
As long as it doesn't impact other people
and the work gets done.
I don't care when they work.
The next thing is we wanted to learn
the distinction between
work, play, and family.
Most people drag their asses to work
and they can hardly wait for the weekend
and be with their family
and do their sports and stuff,
so we wanted to blur
that whole distinction.
In fact, for awhile there we were having
young mothers come to work with the baby,
the newborn baby, and babies in a box
on their desk.
(audience laughing)
Cardboard box.
So we didn't wanna leave our family
and disappear for eight hours a day,
and plus I've always had
a very high percentage
of women working at Patagonia.
We probably have I think
79% or something right now,
and they're in high level positions,
and didn't wanna lose 'em
when they got pregnant, so my wife started
a childcare center, on
site childcare center,
which is one of the first ones
ever in America.
(audience applauding)
So the other thing is we wanted
to be surrounded by friends,
so we wanted to hire friends,
friends of friends, and we wanted to hire
passionate outdoor people,
or people who had a passion for something.
You know the high school kid
that sits there and watches television
for six hours a day, with kind of a drool
coming out of the side of his mouth
and their brain is more dead
than when they're sleeping.
There's no hope for those kind of people.
I'd much rather get a young
criminal or something.
(audience cheering)
So yeah, we wanted to be
surrounded by friends,
and so we wanted to hire
these kind of people
and then teach 'em business,
rather than hire business people
and then try to instill a passion
for the outdoors.
So at the same time, I kind of,
when I came back, I started writing
a philosophy of business,
from those values,
and that's what this book is about.
It's a philosophical book on
different aspects of business,
and I read about 50 books on, I figured,
I woke up one day and I realized, okay,
I am a businessman,
and it looks like this is
gonna be my life's work.
I better figure out what I'm doing.
(audience laughing)
So I went out and read
about 50 books on business,
a lot of books on
Japanese management style,
which is totally different than the US.
I figured they had a lot to teach us.
Scandinavian style of management,
I mean all kinds of stuff,
just to educate myself,
because I knew that we couldn't do it
the usual way, and that, plus for me
the only enjoyable part of business
or the most enjoyable
part of the business,
since I'm kind of a contrarian
is breaking the rules,
and then making it work.
I mean that's why it's taken me 15 years
to write this book 'cause I didn't wanna
write a book and then go out of business,
go bankrupt right away.
(audience laughing)
I had to make sure it works.
And so then I took 15 people at a time,
and we spent a week, or five days,
going to different areas up in the hills
in the Los Padres and stuff,
and doing the same thing.
Instead of talking about our values,
we started talking about
a philosophy of business,
and I was teaching everybody
in the company these philosophies,
and I didn't trust anybody else to do it.
I figured it just had to come from me.
I didn't want it diluted,
and I did that with every single person
in the company.
And now we have over a
thousand employees worldwide,
and that's one reason
why I wrote this book.
I'm getting burned out on this stuff.
(audience laughing)
Well when I was saying
that we had become unsustainable,
about the same time I started seeing
a lot more devastation
of the natural world,
traveling around in Africa,
where I'd been there
10 or 20 years before,
and I started seeing how
badly things were going,
and in this country, you go try
to fish a stream that used to have
lots of fish, and now it's just a sewer.
And I started thinking about another part
to our mission statement.
Our original mission statement
was make the best quality product,
and we always felt that
something is perfected
not when you can't add
anything more to it,
but when you can't take anything away.
And it's kind of the difference between
an old fashioned Cadillac,
that was so butt ugly that they had
to put all kinds of chrome breasts on it
and stuff, you know?
Compared to a Ferrari in those days,
it didn't have any chrome on it.
I mean, it was just those beautiful lines,
and so that's always been our philosophy,
but then I thought we needed another part
to our mission statement,
because really getting concerned
about the natural world,
and I was very concerned
about never having a company
that was unsustainable again,
so we added in the second part,
which says cause no unnecessary harm,
and it doesn't say cause no harm,
because there's no way you can ever
manufacture a product
without causing harm.
And according to the second
law of thermodynamics,
entropy, you basically end up
with probably more waste
than you end up with
in the final product.
There's no such thing as sustainability.
There's a beginning and end to everything,
as any Buddhist will tell ya.
And the only sustainability
that I know if, the only
thing that comes close
to sustainability is probably
hunting and gathering
on a very small scale.
The only economic activity
is probably organically grown agriculture,
'cause the energy comes from the sun,
and the sun is free,
but everything else causes
an incredible amount
of waste and pollution,
but climbing in Yosemite taught me
an important lesson, another Zen lesson,
that what's important is not the end goal,
like in Zen archery, you
don't focus on the target.
You spend years learning how to do
all the different movements
and shooting an arrow,
until finally you
perfect all the movements
that then you can hit the bullseye
with your eyes closed.
And climbing in Yosemite,
you do a 10 day climb
on El Capitan and you get to the top,
and guess what?
There's nothing there.
(audience laughing)
It's just flat up there.
So what's important is how you climb.
And if you compromise the process,
I think compromise is
the work of the devil.
Somehow we've, in government particularly,
they love compromise.
Compromise is Solomon
cutting the baby in half
and giving half a baby to each mother,
who's worrying over whose baby it was.
So (laughs) I don't know how I got
carried away on that one.
(audience laughing)
(laughs) I always felt
that a responsible farmer
leaves the land in better shape
than when he received it.
The forester doesn't just clear cut
and then plant a monocrop,
but takes just what's needed
to keep the forest healthy
and then leaves trees
for the next generation,
and then a responsible government
makes its decisions on the society
being here at least seven generations
into the future, instead
of one or two years.
But somehow business is exempt
from that responsibility.
American style of business
is you're supposed
to grow this business as fast
as you possibly can.
You don't have to make a profit.
You just show lots of growth,
so that you can have an IPO,
sell a bunch of stock to some suckers,
and then you retire to seize your world
and play golf the rest of your life.
Well, I don't believe that is right.
I always felt that if the farmer
has this responsibility, well so do I,
as an owner of a company.
And so we decided to put our company
in a path to where we would be here
a hundred years from now,
so all the decisions made
are for the long term,
which means we can't grow 15% a year,
because one time at an all company meeting
I started putting a one
and a bunch of zeroes
on butcher paper all around the room,
and I said, this is how big we're gonna be
if we continue growing at 40% a year
for the next 40 years.
It was a bazillion dollars.
I mean, it was so ridiculous
you can't believe it,
and so we decided to
grow at a natural growth,
so natural growth means that
when the customer tells you that
they're frustrated in buying your stuff.
They just got the catalog
and you're already sold out,
that you need to make more,
but we don't advertise on inner city buses
to try to get gang kids to
buy our black down jackets
instead of Timerland or North Face.
The reason we got in the
trouble in the first place
is that with this Synchilla
we were selling stuff to people
who wanted it but didn't need it.
Whenever you're in that situation,
you're a victim of the economy.
The economy is gonna go up and down,
and you're gonna go up and down
like a yo yo, and particular
if you really follow
the fashion trends,
and then you're really
in a scary situation.
So we made a lot of decisions then
to try to be here a
hundred years from now,
and from then on, we
controlled our growth,
and we put ourselves,
I mean you could call it
a path towards sustainability.
It's the process towards
sustainability that counts,
and we also accepted the fact
that you can't have it all.
And very few businesses will accept that.
We turn away business all the time.
I mean, our advertising budget
is one half of one percent of sales,
which is nothing in our kind of business.
We want people to come to us.
We want to have loyal customers
who tell their friends,
and then if we grow 3%, 4% a year,
we can be very profitable at that,
and that's fine.
I could call Nordstrom's tomorrow
and probably get a five
million dollar order
out of them or something like that,
but that would put us on a suicide course.
I've always believed that
there's a proper size
for any endeavor,
and I think there's a proper size
for my company.
I use kind of a metaphor to show
for what we were trying to do,
which is make the best product and stuff,
imagine a little French restaurant
that spends 10 years in getting
their first Michelin star,
another 10 years to get their second,
and then 25 years,
they've been in business,
they finally get their
third Michelin star,
and they're one of the 10 best restaurants
in the world, and then they say, okay,
we've made it, so now
let's put in 50 tables.
Well there are no three
star French restaurants
with 50 tables.
It's impossible.
In Japan, the very best
restaurants in Japan
like in Kyoto, it costs you $450,
$500 to eat there.
The size is dictated by the fact
that the chef is the owner,
'cause you can't hire a chef.
Only the owner has the passion
to really have one of
these great restaurants,
and the size of the restaurant
has to be so that the chef is cooking
and is waiting on the
customer at the same time,
so he has to see his
customers right there,
so they're tiny.
They're very small.
So for what we wanna do, for our values,
we can't have a large company.
We have to start hiring
more and more MBAs,
which we don't wanna do.
Anyway, we got out of the crisis,
and we've been doing
pretty well ever since.
In fact, the other value
that we wanted to have
was to get out of debt.
I didn't wanna ever
deal with bankers again,
and we're pretty close to that right now,
but the last philosophy
that I kind of wrote
was fairly recently,
and it's our environmental philosophy,
and I think it applies to a business,
or to individuals.
You can think of it as something
that you could do yourself,
because if you're an alcoholic,
you have to confront yourself and say,
I am an alcoholic before anything happens
to stop drinking.
I mean, we just admit
that we're polluters.
We're using up non renewable resources,
and we're making consumer products,
and we're part of the problem.
So we're trying to be on the process
of minimizing the damage we do,
and we have a five step
program for doing that.
The number one is to
lead an examined life.
I think most of the damage caused
to the environment and to nature
is caused unintentionally,
and it's just from all of
us just blundering along
not questioning what we do.
If you wanna feed your
family healthy food,
you gotta know where it comes from, right?
You can't just go to the supermarket
and buy vegetables.
I mean, the tomatoes
might come from Mexico,
where they still use DDT,
or we're still using
all kinds of different pesticides
on our vegetables here,
so you gotta know.
Sometimes you gotta know the farmer,
or you gotta, so it's the same thing
if you wanna kind of clean up your act,
you gotta lead an examined life,
and for us in the clothing business,
this means asking a lot of questions.
Toyota has a management technique
that they use to solve problems.
If our government used this technique,
you'd see a big difference,
but they say government is not interested
in solving problems.
It just rearranges them and.
(audience laughing)
So okay, so we started an
environmental assessment program,
and we hired some people
to start asking these questions.
So one of the first questions we asked is
of all the fibers used in making clothing,
which are the most damaging,
and which are the least damaging?
Well there's no books on this stuff,
and it takes a long time
to find some answers,
but finally we find out
that, of all the fibers,
at first we thought, oh,
it's gotta be synthetics.
That stuff is, I mean they were made
out of petroleum and stuff.
But we find out that
the most damaging fiber
by far is 100% pure cotton.
Those beautiful little cotton balls
on babies' skins that you see in ads,
that's the worst.
In fact, it probably uses more petroleum
than making synthetics,
because all our
agriculture uses petroleum.
I have a fact in the book here
that I got out of National Geographic.
It takes eight barrels of petroleum
to produce one cow (laughs).
So anyway, the reason
industrially grown cotton
is so bad is that it uses 25%
of the world's pesticides
and insecticides,
and only occupies 3% of
the world's farmland.
And some of these chemicals are so toxic
that they cost $500 a gallon,
and in some areas of the world,
they spray the fields as much as 20 times
in the season, so I took a little trip
to the Central Valley,
the San Joaquin Valley
here and went to some cotton fields,
and boy it was an education.
It was a real eye opener.
I mean they're killing fields.
There's nothing out there that's alive.
There's no birds, there's no insects.
There's no weeds.
There's just these little canals
of toxic water, and the cancer rate's
10 times normal.
There's crop dusters flying over
right over the workers, doesn't matter.
And there's no outlet to
that San Joaquin Valley.
There's no river that goes to the ocean,
so all of that flows out into lower areas
and creates these huge
ponds, like Kesterson.
You've probably heard of that.
And then they hire these guys
to sit on lawn chairs with shotguns
and keep the water fowl from landing,
so that they don't have
chicks with three beaks
and four legs and stuff like that.
And I came back and I said okay,
(laughs) I don't wanna be in business.
I didn't wanna be in
business in the first place,
but I really don't wanna be in business
if I have to use
industrially grown cotton,
and cotton was 20% of our sales,
and I said I don't care.
I'm not gonna do this.
It's kind of like you have a company,
you're one of the best
employers in America,
you're hiring people and
you give 'em great benefits,
but you're making landmines.
But you're making great landmines,
the highest quality landmines.
(audience laughing)
And you go to Cambodia and you see
all these people walking around
with one arm, one leg,
and you see the results
of your landmines, and so,
so I gave the company two years
to get out of making anything
out of industrially grown cotton,
and you don't just call
your fabric supplier,
you say oh, you know,
that 10,000 yards of shirting
I ordered last week,
switch that to organically grown.
(laughs) A few companies had tried
using organic cotton.
Esprit tried it, Vanity Fair tried it,
but what they did is they tried
a little separate line,
and they figured that
well, if this takes off,
then we'll grow it, and if it doesn't,
we got our regular business going,
so they weren't really
committed like I was.
I just told the company, that's it.
Either we make this work,
or we're never gonna use cotton again.
And so it mobilized the entire company,
and I've never seen the
company do better work.
And they were all, everybody
went to the Central Valley.
They all saw this, they came back,
they were all absolutely committed,
and we started talking to organic farmers
and sometimes cosigning their loans
so that they could get
a loan from the bank
'cause the bank wouldn't
loan 'em any money
if they grew organically.
We had to go to find a gin
that would process our cotton,
'cause the gin separates the
seed from the cotton ball,
and these gins are just dripping
with cotton seed oil,
and the oil is where
all the chemicals are concentrated.
One of the chemicals is Agent Orange,
'cause they use that
to defoliate the plants
so the mechanical pickers can pick.
Well anyway, cotton seed
oil is not regulated
by the FDA.
Somehow they've got it so that
they don't have to worry about that.
And check out your chips someday.
If there's any cottonseed oil in there,
don't eat it, and then
they feed the cottonseeds,
after they press the
oil out to the cattle,
so you're getting that in your beef,
anyway, we can't run.
(audience laughing)
(laughs)
(audience applauding)
We can't very well run our organic cotton
through this gin without
convincing the guy
to clean it first, and then we get
to the spinner who makes
the yarn and stuff,
makes the fiber,
and he doesn't wanna deal with us,
because our stuff is coming in
with seeds and stems and sticks,
little pieces of leaves,
because we didn't use defoliant.
The farmer had to do it in a natural way,
kind of starve the plant for water,
just at the right time
of the year and stuff,
so I can tell you that
it wasn't easy switching over,
but we did it, and we found
a few good partners, and we convinced 'em
that this was gonna be the future,
and we made it work, and.
(audience applauding)
But that's only one question.
We're supposed to ask five questions.
So then we said okay,
well what are we gonna do,
how about the dyes
that you use for dying cotton?
I mean, we never had to worry about this,
'cause we just call a fabric supplier,
and he'd come with a big book,
and we'd look at all these different
prints and fabrics and say, oh yeah,
give me this, give me that.
So how about dyes?
So we tried to find out
if these dyes are toxic.
Well nobody wants to tell you,
and nobody even knows.
The people making the dyes haven't even
asked the question.
Well finally we find out, yeah,
this stuff's toxic, but there's a company
in West Germany that makes cotton dyes
that are non toxic,
except one color is toxic,
so okay, so we don't do that color.
Okay, that's two questions.
Well, where are they gonna dye this stuff?
Is a big outfall going into a river
from the dye house?
So we sent somebody over to Portugal,
'cause we're gonna make flannel shirts
out of 'em, so they go there
and sure enough, here's
all these dye houses
on this river that goes
into Porto in Portugal,
huge river, big outfall pipes
going right into the river.
But the last dye house
down at the mouth of the river
can't use the water 'cause it's jet black,
so they bought all this fancy machinery
to clean the water so they can use it,
so they clean it, and
then they dye their stuff,
and then they run it back
through the machinery again,
and it comes out pure into the river.
So there you go.
Now we got a choice.
Education leaves you choices.
The uneducated person has no choices.
He's gotta go through life like this.
So anyway,
so then one more question,
well what's gonna happen
to this cotton clothing
when the customer is all done with it?
I mean, we should be
responsible for that product
all the way from birth
till death, and beyond.
I feel a company should be responsible
not only for the product,
but for how the product is made.
And so cotton, when you're done with it,
if you bought a pair of bell bottom pants,
and suddenly they're out of fashion,
you throw 'em away, right?
Or you give them to Salvation Army
and then 15 years later
it comes back into fashion,
and people are rushing to buy 'em again,
so that was a problem, so
we were absolutely committed
to not putting fashion
into our sportswear.
If the collar points are five inches long,
well we don't make 'em five inches.
We do 'em three inches,
so that they're never in fashion,
never out of fashion.
(audience laughing)
And the difference
between a Hawaiian shirt
that you can buy at a
vintage Hawaiian shirt store
for $300 and one that's 50 cents
at the Salvation Army,
they're both Hawaiian shirts,
but one is classic.
One never goes out of style,
and the patterns line up,
and there's a big
difference between the two,
so we realized that the
most important thing
we could do is to try to make
the clothes last as long as possible.
And not go in and out of fashion,
because we're responsible for 'em,
but I can tell ya
one thing that's just
happened very recently,
that is really exciting,
it's the most exciting
thing that's happened
in the company in a long time,
we've partnered with a Japanese mill
that's just spent 100 million dollars
in a recycling plant,
where they're gonna recycle polyester.
Now we've been making
40 different products,
all our fleece and stuff,
made out of recycled soda pop bottles,
but when you're done with those products,
and they're all worn out,
you throw them away,
but now we're telling our customers
that when you're done with
your Capilene underwear
which is polyester,
you bring it back to us and wash it first.
(audience laughing)
Especially the thongs (laughs).
And then we're gonna
bundle that stuff up,
and we're gonna send it back to Japan,
and all the ships going back to Japan
are empty anyway.
(audience laughing)
So the shipping rates are really low.
We've calculated all the energy usage,
and it's gonna go to this plant,
and they're gonna melt this stuff down,
and take it to it's original polymer,
and then make fiber,
and then we're gonna make
more underwear out of it,
so we're gonna complete the circle,
what Bill McDonough
calls cradle to cradle,
and it's never been done with clothing,
and we're starting with
our Capilene underwear,
and we're gonna be eventually doing it
with all our polyester,
and we just designed a pair of surf trunks
that instead of nylon, it's polyester,
with a view towards a
couple years from now
we'll be able to do the
same thing with that.
We're making one shell
that's all polyester,
and we're working with another factory
that's gonna do the same thing
with nylon 6, so we're used to
recycling aluminum cans,
and making more aluminum cans.
When you buy an automobile,
95% of the steel in that automobile
comes from another automobile,
and so now we're gonna
do it with clothing,
and right now probably the least damaging
clothes you can buy are fiber
that you can make clothes
out of is probably hemp,
but I can see that soon it'll
probably be polyester, and nylon 6,
because in the process,
we only lose 5% of the material,
and it only takes 20% of the energy
to make a new product
from the old product,
then if you made petroleum.
So anyway, I hope we're not all wearing
these red leisure polyester
suits someday, but.
(audience laughing)
So anyway, the second
part of my five steps
is to clean up your act.
After you've educated yourself,
then act on it.
And then the third part is
we're always gonna be polluters,
and we're always gonna be consumers.
We're not citizens anymore.
We're consumers.
It's not the government that wants
or oil companies that wanted
to drill in the Arctic
National Wildlife Refuge.
It's us.
We're the ones.
And so, we're never gonna be perfect,
so we gotta do some penance,
so that's where we take 1% of our sales,
it's not 1% of profits.
It's 1% of our total sales,
and we give that away to organizations
that are doing some good.
Since the mid 80's we've given away
about 22 million dollars,
and what we do is.
(audience applauding)
Well that's a lot of your money.
(laughs) Thank you.
(audience laughing)
What we do with it is we give it away
to environmental causes,
and people ask us why we don't give
to social causes.
Well, I think if you start asking
the five questions with any cause,
with any problem in the world,
you'll get down to the real cause
is an environmental cause,
whether it's the hurricane in New Orleans
or poverty in Africa and genocide,
it's all, if you ask enough questions,
it gets down to us destroying our planet,
and government is not
interested in causes.
They're interested in working on symptoms.
One out of eight women in this room
are gonna get breast cancer,
and that's up from one in forty
in World War II,
so you can't tell me it's genetics.
It has to have some environmental cause,
and yet I've found out
in writing this book
that only 3% of the monies
that go to breast cancer research
go to trying to find environmental causes
of breast cancer.
All the rest goes to finding cures.
Well, (laughs) your average house
has 5,000 toxic chemicals, most of which
haven't been tested
to see if they give you cancer.
There's only been under
a thousand chemicals
that have been tested
to see if they give you cancer.
So you can give money to
breast cancer research,
but give it to organizations
that are working
on stopping the use of these pesticides
and these toxic chemicals.
(audience applauding)
So of the powerful forces in our society,
whether it's federal government
and state government, local governments,
there's one that's more
powerful than any of them,
and that's civil democracy,
and that's who we give our money to,
is 30,000 activist organizations
working on environmental
causes in America.
Think about this country was started,
a bunch of activists dumped some tea
in Boston Harbor.
People say, well Lincoln freed the slaves.
Well, Lincoln just wanted to keep
the Union together, really.
The slaves were being
encourage to flee the South
through the Underground Railroad
funded by Northern philanthropists,
a bunch of activists.
And on Civil Rights legislation,
it wasn't Johnson.
It was Rosa Parks, a senior citizen,
refused to get off a bus,
and little black kids refused to go
to segregated schools.
Women's suffrage, Vietnam,
(laughs) a bunch of activists
got us out of that stupid war,
so I really believe in civil democracy,
and in fact one of the lessons of nature
that is really important for me
is nature loves diversity.
It's always trying to make new species,
it hates monoculture.
It hates a monocrop.
It just loves its diversity,
and why not solve all our problems
with hundreds of thousands of little NGOs,
Non Government Organizations around
that are doing good work,
instead of just bloated
bureaucracies and stuff?
(audience applauding)
(instrumental pop music)